I just couldn't resist this
fun, colorful variegated yarn.
It has short color repeats
and it was on sale.
It will be perfect for
a Susanna's blanket.
Now I experimented a bit and I found that
I liked tension six on my bulky machine,
so I made a swatch.
It that tension.
Okay.
I know this is just a blanket, but without
a swatch, I can't be sure if I have enough
yarn or even what size to knit
with the yarn that I have.
This is a 100% acrylic yarn, so I just
used a little bit of steam, detain the
curl, tame those edges to
make it easier to measure.
I've knit a proper swatch.
And measured between the yarn markers for
the stitches and between the marked rows
for the rows.
If you aren't familiar with knitting a
proper swatch, please visit the swatching
classroom, knititnow.com/swatch.
With my gauge established.
I'll use my swatch and estimate
how much Yarn I'll need.
I'll measure the entire
swatch from edge to edge.
And I'll weigh it in grams.
Armed with this info, I'm ready
to start building my pattern.
Now, I'm not sure what size
blanket I'll be knitting.
This is going to be for charity and it's
going to be based on how much yarn I have,
so I'll select bassinet size for now.
Now notice that the pattern prompts you
with a standard size, but you can adjust
it if you like.
And this might come in handy later.
If you work in centimeters.
Select centimeters here.
I've entered my gauge in in four inches.
I could put some notes in right
here for future reference.
With the choices I've made, I"m generating
a pattern for a blanket that's 16 inches
wide and 36 inches long.
Notice that I'm immediately prompted
to check if I have enough needles.
Now, if I'm knitting a larger blanket, the
needle limitations of our needle bed might
come into play here.
The green button, will
get the pattern started.
This pop up again confirms my choices,
and in case you missed it, it confirms the
number of needles needed
for the width that I chose.
Now, if I didn't have enough needles at
this point, I could go back and adjust the
width.
Click the blue button,
and build the pattern.
Now I'll come back to this page again.
This is where I started and the details of
my custom pattern are listed right here.
I'm still not sure what size, so
I'm going to use the yarn estimator.
When I click the white yarn button,
I'll be prompted to
enter in my swatch data.
I measured my width to be 7.5 inches
by 8.5 inches, and the swatch weighs 22
grams.
Now for this small blanket,
I'll need about 198 grams.
I have lots more yard than that, so
I'm going to try a different size.
I'll start again, but this time I'll
select the next size up, which is a crib
size.
I'll enter my gauge and the
details for the pattern.
It's prompting me that I need 54 needles
this time, but still, no problem.
When I come back to this page, notice the
new crib size pattern, my newest pattern
is at the top of the list
with all of its details.
I'll click the yarn button to calculate
the yard based again on my swatch.
And for this larger blanket,
I'm going to need 559 grams.
If I want to make a change, I can either
choose a different size or modify the
dimensions of the pattern that I built.
The view button will display my pattern.
This page repeats all the
details of my pattern.
To get knitting, I'll
click blanket instructions.
The Knit it NOw, pattern format is
designed to be viewed on an iPad or a
tablet, right at your knitting machine.
You can watch the included videos
right from the pattern page.
You can also hide and show the various
sections, making it easier to keep track
of where you are when you're knitting.
If you prefer a printed
pattern, there are two options.
Click the print button and you can print
the instructions as they're displayed on
the screen, the videos and any detailed
instructions on the right hand side, they
won't clutter up the printed page.
You'll be just printing
the knitting instructions.
You also can choose to
download a PDF of the pattern.
Again, the videos and detailed
instructions aren't included.
Enough talk.
I'm ready to get knitting.